- A different ANA presentation.
Marketer, entrepreneur, social
media guru, internet personality
and agency owner.
Your next speaker is not afraid
to tell it like he sees it.
Fresh out of college, he took
his family wine business and
grew from $3 million to
$60 million in just five years.
From there, he set his
sights on marketing,
social media
and entrepreneurship.
With us to discussed the notion
of marketing in the year we live
in is the CEO of digital agency
VaynerMedia, Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
(energetic music)
Morning.
(single man cheers)
(laughs) I'm really
excited to be here.
As somebody who has comes from
outside the industry over the
last seven years I've become
very fond of my contemporaries
and the creative and strategic
people in this industry and
I've enjoyed it quite a bit.
My back story is very immigrant.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
I came to the U.S.
I lived in a studio apartment
a fourth of the size of
this stage with my family.
My dad got a job as a
stock boy in a liquor store.
We were super poor the first
six, seven years of being here.
And eventually, how many people
are immigrants or
children of immigrants?
Raise your hand.
Awesome. So you guys,
a lot of you know.
There's a really hard-core
secret immigrants have.
It's a tried and true strategy.
Don't spend money on dumb shit.
(audience laughter)
That's what my parents
did for first 5 to 10 years.
We saved and eventually my dad
bought a small liquor store
in Springfield, New Jersey.
This industry is so
interesting to me.
Besides the last political
question, most of the questions
that were asked of all these
wonderfully smart people the
part that I was most fascinated
by as I watched that was who
gets to be the judge and jury?
Right? Who gets to
be the judge of quality?
Who gets to be the judge and
jury has been the number one
question that I've had since
I've entered this industry.
'Cause, you see,
my story is simple.
When you go into a family
business and you're a first
generation immigrant and you
have to work for two bucks an
hour as a 14-year-old in a
liquor store, there is no
Cannes Lion Award that justifies
your marketing strategy.
There is no modeling mix. Right?
There's no subjectivity.
My KPI was to sell
more Pinot Noir.
If my marketing worked,
my family ate more
and had more stuff.
And so, I come from a background
where I disproportionately
respect sales and marketing in
very separate silos but I find
myself in the last decade where
a lot of people mix the two and
debate the two and don't
have as much vested interest as
entrepreneurs and business
to actually dissect the two.
What I'm excited to talk
about this morning is deploying
dramatic common sense in a
2017 world to an industry that
I've had an unbelievable
time getting to know.
When I first got here, I came
out of building a liquor store
from $3 to $60 million in
five years with no money.
How did I do that?
You have to make
every penny work.
Not only was it
doing $3 million a year,
we were running
on 10% gross profit.
So we had $300,000 before
expenses to make
our business grow.
I did that because while Sherry,
Lehmann's and Zachy's and Sam's
and K&amp;L and Wine.com with it's
$188 million in funding were
doing the Wine Spectator and
the New York Times and
Wall Street Journal and
direct-mail and outdoor,
I decided that launching an
e-commerce site in 1996 was a
good idea instead of
opening a second store,
this was going to be
my second and third store.
The other thing I did was
I started an email
newsletter in 1996.
How many people here have
done or have been close to email
marketing in their career?
Please raise your hand.
Great, you're going
to love this one.
In 1996, 200,000 people
on my email newsletter and
I had 91.3% open rates.
(audience groans and laughter)
- Not because I was a genius
or the copy was so great.
It was 'cause nobody
was email marketing.
The one thing I promise you more
than anything, more than I know
that the sun will come up
tomorrow I know one true fact:
marketers ruin everything.
(audience laughter)
It's what we do.
Two-and-a-half years ago I was
so pumped when I decided that
Snapchat was going to be the
next frontier and I couldn't
wait to fuck up
that little ghost.
(audience laughter)
You wanted to
follow your friends,
I wanted to sell you shit.
Right?
So that's been my life.
Email was this new thing.
I was like wait a minute, I can
reach people instead of doing
direct mail and
paying for the paper
and paying for the stamp,
I can do this and wait a minute
I was selling the wine Opus One,
Chateau Lafite three to four
months ahead of my competition
because between the time they
have to make the catalog and get
it into your home,
I was already in their inbox
and here's the punchline.
My friends, I am not a
digitalist or a futurist or
definitely not a
social media guru.
What I am is I really
give a shit about one thing.
I have one pitch.
If you're a baseball fan,
I basically equate my career
much more to Mariano Rivera
than anything else.
He was the Yankees closer for
15 years, he had one pitch and
nobody could hit it.
I've played the same game
since I was six years old.
When I started my
entrepreneurial career,
I started a lemonade stand.
But I started five of them.
I manipulated my friends to
stand behind the lemonade stands
all day and what I did was
I walked up and down the streets
of Edison, New Jersey,
it was 1982 a different time,
and I would watch cars drive.
This is how sick and broken
of a human being I am, as a
six-year-old I would walk up and
down the streets of New Jersey
and I would sit, sit and watch
people drive on the street and
try to figure out which tree or
pole was better for me to put my
lemonade stand sign on because
I was following their eyes.
And basically the rest of my
life has been one hard core
religion around attention.
I don't care about
traditional or digital.
I stand here today and a lot of
people know me and I think I'm
all about Facebook and Snapchat
and Instagram and I am but
I will stand here today,
my long-term plan, I built an
agency from 30 to 800 people
in the last five years from
$3 to $100 million in revenue.
No M&amp;A, all growth but my main
goal is predicated on building a
private equity firm on top of
it because while great companies
like the one the presented right
before me can only spend money
on their 7 to 12 monster brands,
there's ungodly amounts of great
brands in that portfolio
that are going to be sold off.
I'm going to buy those brands
and I'm gonna run
them through my machine.
That is my plan of how I am
going buy the New York Jets.
Right?
That's my strategy.
(audience laughter and applause)
Not so fun right now.
So for me what's been
interesting about building my
agency is that we're not so
special, we're not so great.
What we are is we are
disproportionately aligned with
our clients because
I want to become our clients.
My goal is not to run on the
highest margin so I can sell my
agency for eight times EBITA
to a fucking holding company.
My goal is to build an
actual business and
what that's done is--
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
So what it's done is it's made
me want to break and rewire my
first corporate
America meeting of my life.
So in 2006 and '07 I did
something super smart.
I invested in Facebook and
Twitter very early on
and then Tumblr.
And then Uber.
I'm mainly saying
that to humblebrag but
it's an important thing.
I decided that this one pitch
that I had, because I built
Wine Library on email marketing,
then the day Google AdWords came
out I bought a word wine for
five cents a click before they
raised the minimum to 10 cents a
click and I sold a lot of wine.
As a matter of fact, it's
the great regret of my life.
It is why I will pound you at
some point in my 18 minutes here
on really understanding what's
happening in the
Facebook ad ecosystem.
It is the 100% replication of
early Google and I was selling a
ton of wine but I should of
put all my money into it because
when you have a once in a
generation arbitrage of
attention that is grossly
underpriced by the market,
you need to become pot-committed
to extract all the value.
And even though I grew my dad's
business from $3 to $60 million,
the truth is and this is not fun
for me to say to you, it should
have been $3 to $150 million
because all that direct mail
money and all that billboard
money and all that
New York Times money should have
went all-in to Google because
I would extracted such
phenomenal ROI.
My career took an interesting
turn four months after
YouTube came out.
YouTube came out, I took a look
at it, it was another moment in
my life like e-com, like email
marketing, like Google AdWords
where I felt it.
I was like this is
going to be big.
And I started a wine show
called Wine Library TV.
It was the first time that
advertising wasn't
driving my revenue.
It was content.
I was producing a show.
The show was pretty basic.
I sat in front of a camera
for 20 minutes and
drank four bottles of wine.
(audience laughter)
Best gig I ever had.
And at its height hundreds of
thousands of people a day were
watching it and I was
selling lots and lots of wine.
And that taught what I've always
known and I want to say this
before I go into the next part
of my rant because if I don't
say it, it will get lost.
My absolute belief is that
creative is the
variable of success.
That the creative is
the variable of success.
The problem is I fundamentally
do not believe how this
marketplace brings
creative to life.
If you go home and tell a
non-marketing person this story
I want to know their reaction.
Hey, Sally, best friend,
let me actually tell you
about my business.
This is now the general
industry, no agency, no brand.
This is the net
score and you know it.
Here's the bottom line.
Here is how most
brands work in 2017.
We're there already, right?
A human being, and one or two of
her contemporaries come up with
some creative ideas for a brand.
They sit in a room, they get
some insights, they have some
strategy but in general
sometimes, by the way, they come
up with creative ideas.
Humans.
Three, five, six, seven.
They then narrow down their five
to seven ideas to one to two,
maybe three, because, you know,
the meeting to pitch this only
has a certain amount of time.
The person on the other end is
normally, by high percentage,
somebody who went to business
school and was taught to run a
P&amp;L and a business.
That person sits in a room,
lets the other person present.
They watch a couple of videos,
talk about other cockamamie
horse shit and then those
two people at the top,
the brand person and the
creative person
from that agency,
those two human beings decide
what the creative is the brand.
Now what's interesting
about that creative is
it has to be 100% vanilla.
You know why?
Because when they deploy that
creative 60 to 70% of the money,
maybe 50 but probably closer to
70 if you factor in the other
channels besides television,
but 50% of that money is spent
in the form of making
a 30 second video.
That 30 second video in 2017 is
deployed the following way;
it plays in-between television.
Linear television.
Let's get really honest
here for one second, friends.
By show by show of hands, and
remember lying is the devil,--
(audience laughter)
by show of hands, how many
people here in late 2016 when
they watch television,
outside of live sports,
watch it on your time?
Not when it actually airs.
DVR, TiVo, on your
time, raise your hand.
Oh, weird, everybody.
(audience laughter)
And of all of you that just
raised your hands, if you're not
doing Netflix and HBO Go which
is by the way the majority of
the emerging trends but if
you're DVRing 'cause there's
unbelievable content on network
television, how many of you in
2016 fast forward every
single commercial
when given the option?
Raise your hands.
Yeah. All of you.
And by the way, let's all agree
this is not a
14-year-old girl crowd.
We're old.
(audience laughter)
And miraculously, miraculously
if that commercial that you
spend 40, 50, 60, 70%
of your money and
energy on gets lucky
and actually airs in front of
you because I don't know you
dropped your fucking
remote of the bed,
(audience laughter)
when it airs there's not a
single person here when that
thing airs that doesn't grab
this and wants to talk about
what LeBron just did
or what she just wore.
I promise you one thing you can
count all the impressions you
want for the rest of your
life including the single worst
execution of marketing today
which is programmatic digital
banner buying on
desktop computers.
(audience laughter and applause)
And you know it 'cause nobody
here is going to WomensDaily.org
bottom left-hand corner
below the fold to see
a fucking banner.
(audience laughter and applause)
And so we're
playing an attention game.
The first meeting I ever went
to incorporate America in
south Jersey, big CPG brand.
I'm super pumped.
I knew a lot of people.
I was very close with Bob Kilts
the former CEO of Nabisco,
Kraft and Gillette so I knew the
game somewhat from afar.
I knew that some many people
that were winning in 2009 after
I made these big
internet investments and had my
successful business I knew I was
going to have to each shit for a
decade to build a client service
business, to build a foundation
for me to build my thing.
So I came in with as much
humility as I could which is
hard but I came in.
I wanted to listen, I was
excited and here's the first
meeting I sat in.
I promised myself,
I even called my mom.
I said, "Mom, I'm not
going to say a word.
"I'm gonna listen.
I'm gonna do it."
Walked in and
it's an IAC or an IAT,
lots of agencies are there.
And the first PR
agency stands up.
And this PR agency's tells this
brand that they got 88.3 million
impression for the
brand the month before.
I looked when I was curious
because I come from digital they
counted all of Huffington Post's
monthly traffic,
the whole net score,
for a mention somewhere
deep four clicks into
that ecosystem.
And everybody clapped
and the next person came.
Some insights type thing and
they said that the Millard brand
study was one of the great
things that they've
ever seen in their lives.
And everybody clapped and then
we watched a video and everybody
got emotional and clapped.
And then everybody clapped.
(audience laughter)
And then I looked
at the last page.
And it said that the
brand was down 27%.
(audience laughter)
And that's when I fought but
I couldn't go there I said,
"Look, I know," and by the way,
everybody's making fun of me.
It's 2009 I just put this brand
on Facebook physically
with my fingers.
They're like, "Isn't
that for my daughter?"
2009 is not that long ago.
I know a lot of you have been in
the industry you know the level
of disrespect
these platforms had.
So they make a joke, fine.
And then I just ask a simple
question is, "How in the world
"can we sit in a room for
90 minutes and everything is the
"greatest thing we've ever seen
and the business is down 29%?"
And the MMM said we
were getting huge ROI.
I mean everything.
And then the brand manager and
the senior brand person looked
and they're like,
"Yeah, confusing."
I'm like, "It's not
fucking confusing asshole."
(audience laughter)
I'm like, "It's simple.
"You're scoring on
the wrong shit."
You can you measure
any marketing activity.
The problem is we have a process
right now that was made from
1950 to 2000.
There's a new world.
Attention is in
different places.
I could care less if Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat
exist tomorrow.
I just care about
where your attention is.
How in the world, where we know
the following which is every
single passenger in a car
today is looking at their phone.
Shit, 25% of the people that
are driving are
looking at their phone.
And outdoor media prices go up
because that what always happens
because they're trying to
squeeze the last dollars out.
So I was always confused.
I was confused.
I was saying,
"Why is this happening?"
First, I got mad at
the brand people.
Then I got mad at the agency.
It's the whole ecosystem.
How many people saw
"The Big Short", the movie?
Raise your hand.
Perfect.
I never talk in movies.
My mom scared me when I was
10 so I don't talk in movies.
She said that was bad.
I'm watching "The Big Short",
I'm sitting with my wife and it
was the first time
I ever talked in a movie.
We're watching and
all of a sudden
I just give her
a little this and I go,
"Lizzie this is what's happening
in the advertising industry."
Everybody knows, everybody is
just not in on it from in a
illegal standpoint,
we're just in a machine.
We know what's being scored.
I used to be mad at
you but now I understand.
You can't take this risk.
This is how MMM is stored inside
and you're not going to be
promoted and what if...
We all know.
Great, brand's are up,
you can show creative but
there's a lot of variables.
The money you
pour into trade, trends,
what your competitors are doing.
Creative is a variable of
success, it's just not the only
variable of why a
brand would grow.
So I poke her and I go,
"Lizzie, this is happening in
the advertising industry.
"And I'm the guy with
the weird fucking eye."
(audience laughter)
And by the way I am no hero.
The only reason I even tell this
truth is 'cause my financial
interest isn't vested
in growing my agency.
It is not vested
in other things.
I'm just going
through my North Star.
I'm trying to figure out which
people in here understand that
when you do the behaviors
that make you successful in a
corporate Fortune 500 company
today you are completely going
against what will make you
successful in a corporate
Fortune 500 company
10 to 15 years from today.
I tell my friends that
I get to know I go,
"Look, I know why
you're doing this."
You can't take this bet on
Snapchat even though you are
selling just 13 to 18-year-olds
because it's not
scored internally.
It's not supported by
people two rings above you.
That's why you're
not going doing it.
You believe it.
Hell, I know that you as a human
being think one thing about
marketing and selling but when
you put on your business jersey
and go in every day
you act a different way.
And I used to be mad
but now I understand.
Now I'm mad at the CEOs of the
biggest companies in the world
because they're creating the
scoring and by the way back to
the attention graph, my friends
when I buy my first brand, and
you'll watch me do it, the first
thing I'm going to do is run
multiple Super Bowl ads.
I believe that the number one
underpriced value of attention
in today's marketing
world is the Super Bowl.
Because every single
person watches it.
Whether they watch it during
the game or on
YouTube the week before.
The problem with the current
execution of Super Bowl is the
creative has so much vested
interesting in being a showcase
for agencies for new clients and
for new employees that we're not
making the kind of work in there
that really takes advantage of
having all of America.
There are so many brands in here
that are gonna spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on CRM over
the next decade that they could
accomplished that data
collection in one Super Bowl ad
with the right creative
execution to get everybody to do
something in their funnel.
But as much as I think the
Super Bowl ad is greatest buy in
the world literally the second
most expensive commercial in the
world is the worst.
Because much as we'd like people
to watch commercials during the
Emmys and the Grammys and
NASCAR it is just not the
same attention behavior.
Live sports, a lot of people
have been hitting me up,
you must be pumped
about the NFL ratings.
I'm like I'm not.
I'm not going to use that.
11 of the 18 primetime
games have been blow outs.
That's why the ratings are down.
You could talk about elections,
you can talk
about anything else.
I understand why it's happening
so I'm not gonna
use that cheap shot.
And by the way, DataLogics,
an unbelievable company,
helped grow my business but it's
no different than Nielsens
or Millard Brown.
It was the report
that you accepted.
Fine, but I ask this room and by
the way a room I've really come
to love because when you can
talk about the cross-section of
creative and sales, that's me.
That's what I love.
I love this room.
What I'm scared about is you're
all playing a game for 2016
that's in your vested interest,
as you should because you are
human being, the problem is if
you're not paying attention,
the game that we're all going
to be playing in 2026,
they're gonna judge you poorly.
Please go look back the
last three revolutions,
Industrial Revolutions.
People that got hurt the most
look exactly like
the people in this room.
Which they were making
behavior for the prior game.
They were training
for basketball and
the world made them play hockey.
If you think Uber and airBnB
and all the direct to consumer
brands are gonna love the
subjectiveness of creative or
the horse shit reporting that
has been accepted within this
ecosystem, you are
out of your mind.
So what is the punchline?
The punchline is very simple.
We need real common sense.
I understand why it feels
good to be the holder of the
subjectiveness around the
creative because it justifies
why you're even in the room.
But it needs to be understood.
For example, my creative started
hating me at first because
they thought I was
downplaying it.
I up play it.
In a world that this is now the
television and the television is
the radio, if you understand
that shift and you go read the
history of the transition of
what happened between the radio
and the television and all the
quotes that the television would
never be a viable medium
compared to the radio or you
couldn't do the same creativity.
This is just a history repeating
itself over and over and over.
The creatives, those beautiful
videos we watched, there were
seven more
versions of that video.
And guess what?
If you actually make creative
for this world and you don't do,
everybody likes to talk about
the media inefficiencies
and transparencies.
What about the creative?
What about the creative director
that always wanted to
blow something up?
So that's why they're doing it.
What about creative that always
wanted to meet John Legend?
That's why he's
in the commercial.
What about the hidden cost
in out-of-pocket at scale?
Come on guys.
We know this.
I know you it.
I now know why nobody's talking
about it because we as
human being have to
do what's right for us.
Good, I'm fine.
I understand.
But it doesn't mean that
your marketing properly.
But it doesn't
mean that it's right.
And there's so much opportunity.
It's just black and white.
When people ask me,
"What work are you proud of?"
The work that sold shit.
Black and white.
You want to prove
that creative works?
Great.
Facebook is the birth child
of direct mail and television.
Used hand-in-hand
it is obnoxious.
I can prove to you on any CPG
brand by getting no data back
from our retailers, 'cause we
don't, that it's working because
I can run regional creative
against a baseline always
depletion report standard.
You've got, everybody here's got
brands that have basically sold
the same way for the most part
at Albertson's in Michigan for
the last two years.
Run it and see what happens.
There is an
absolute lack of want
to prove the ROI in the
industry mainly because,
and this is just the truth,
unfortunately, and I'm not mad
at the agencies anymore either,
the fundamental fact is we
have conglomerates that are both
publicly held traded companies
and everybody is out for
their vested interest.
As they should,
I love capitalism.
But the fact of the matter is
everybody's trying to
run on their margin.
And that's what happens and so,
there is so much opportunity
to tell our stories.
That last
presentation was exactly right.
You just need to get 19
at-bats instead of one at-bat.
And you need to run in a way
where the first four at-bats
indicates your
next nine at-bats.
Creatives are gonna be able
to get all nine ideas into the
ecosystem and everybody's
like, "Well, does it ladder?"
You know what I love?
"But Gary, when you do that
does it ladder up to the brand?"
Who chooses?
You, Sally?
You Sally are the only woman on
Earth that knows
if this is on brand?
We have to really understand
that our brands mean different
things to different people.
We have to understand that
there's a totally different
marketplace and most of all,
and this is basic data, the
attention, the attention of the
consumer is shifting at scale.
If I told you what was
happening today
10 years ago
you would not believe it.
The power of computing,
the way we date.
Remember how was taboo
internet dating was? Right?
This is a real opportunity.
It doesn't mean
anything is dead.
This has nothing
to do with dead.
Nothing's dead.
As a matter of fact, you know
what I'm paying attention to?
Drive time radio.
Drive time radio
continues to go down in price.
It's eventually gonna
get super interesting.
I can be sold anything.
Shit, I'll buy smoke signals
and carvings in caves
if you sell it to me for zero.
(audience laughter)
This is not about
this is better than that.
This is about
if you are agnostic,
if you are unemotional,
what's a better
deal than the other?
People always tell me, "But
Gary I'm crushing it on TV and
"programmatic and I'm up 13%."
I'm like, "Hey Rick,
what's wrong with up 44%?"
That's the punchline.
And the opportunity is there
and the truth is I've come to
realize, and I'm happy about
this, I know all of you know.
So now the question is
who's brave enough to have real
conversations internally to
give you some room,
some room to actually do it.
The world's clearly changing
and too many
people in this room are
holding onto the past because it
is because it is in their
vested financial interests.
That's fine and I appreciate it.
I'm not saying you're bad, I'm
saying please just keep in the
back of your mind that that's
for the current game we're
playing and they're going to
pull the rug from underneath you
and you need to know that.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Outstanding.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I said it was going to
be different, didn't I?
- I don't know why
that would be different.
Because at 3 o'clock in the
morning after I pump a couple of
bottles of Rosé into them at
Cannes they say the same shit.
(audience laughter)
- So I was just going to ask
how do we elevate our creative?
- Creative gets elevated when we
accept an ecosystem that gives
us more creative at-bats.
This is not creative.
I believe creative the most.
I just think that an
African-American with four kids
in Houston that's 44 years old
is gonna think differently about
the creative then Sally in
Alaska that's single and 26.
And we play in an ecosystem
where we just push (grunts) and
then we throw four cents at
some interpretation of it.
We are completely
disrespecting attention.
- So the first question on
the screen here I think is
(inaudible) which brands are
knocking it out of the park?
- I have no idea but--
(audience laughter)
- I don't.
You know why?
Because we say brands are
knocking it out of the park
because four trades
give them credit.
This is subjective shit.
You know who's
knocking it out of the park?
The people that are deeply
putting rigor around their
actions for sales.
Sour Patch Kids 'cause
we worked on it, I know.
Go figure, here's the punchline.
This was wild.
When you take
Sour Patch Kids which sells to
12 to 18-year-olds, when you
take it away from running a
commercial on Spike TV that
cost you $800,000 to
make the commercial
when you do that and you take
all that money and you pour it
into Instagram and Snapchat
creative and influencers then
the business grows 60% sales.
Go figure.
(audience laughter)
But it's true, right?
It's true.
If you are running a commercial
for a brand that target audience
is 22 and under,
you're a fuck face.
(audience laughter)
It's getting a little
Jersey up here.
(audience laughter)
People don't get it
and I don't want the
business I just don't want
you to go to your interview to
airBnB in four years and
have that on your resume.
Do you understand?
(audience laughter)
Come on.
Do you understand?
This is real.
Do you understand the channel
conflict wars that are coming
between direct to
consumer brands and
the Fortune 500 CPG companies?
Do you understand when Sally's
Toothpaste is doing $200 million
direct to consumer that Colgate
says wait a minute we have to
compete with this
but then they can't because
CostCo and Albertson's and CVS
won't let them go DTC.
There's real stuff coming.
We've got to take
this way more macro.
There's a lot coming.
Everybody here knows
the world 15 years ago.
How many people are
retiring in 10 years?
And I don't mean you're going
to crush it and get bonuses,
I mean you're old
and you're finished.
(audience laughter)
10 years, raise your hand.
10 years?
Four. Four.
What do you guys think the
world looks like in 10 years?
It's going to be 3X the
innovation we've
seen in the last.
Alexa voice ordering your shit,
smart kitchens,
smart products
reordering itself.
If you're not running on the
treadmill right now doing smart
digital to get ready for the
marathon we're all living,
you're finished as an executive.
(audience laughter)
- I shouldn't just ask Gary.
I should just let
you keep going.
- You know what else though?
You know what else?
I've taken an interesting
turn on this kind of.
What really excites me is I've
gone the route of you because
I realize how many decisions are
made by you but the punchline is
and you're also
helping the business.
The executive that did the
Sour Patch Kids work is doing
way better but Sour Patch Kids
exploded in sales.
But, you know, listen, your
margin as a media buying agency
is very high in programatic
banner, very easy to go to the
up-front at CBS and listen
to Kanye and place media.
You're going to push that.
That's just the truth.
And so but it
doesn't make it right.
- So what do we have to change?
- The whole thing.
(audience laughter)
- That's why there's
2,700 people here.
- But guys, I'm telling
you, gals, listen, go read the
transition of
radio to television.
It is the biggest
preview for you.
The biggest brands in the world
when down, new brands emerged.
The whole beer industry switched
because the emotion and the
vested interest of the media
planners of the time in radio
and they took them to
the Yankees game and
drank a beer with the Mick.
You know?
It's a mistake and again what
really blows my mind is
I know you know it now.
I used to not.
I come from
Silicon Valley
and entrepreneur-land.
I was like you don't know.
You know.
You're just stuck in the game
that your playing and I get it
but really two people
making a subjective call on a
piece of creative and then
giving it some vanilla punchline
like "For the people".
It's never creative.
I can create every one of your
slogans for the next 20 years.
Let me run a quick algorithm of
six common sense words together
and I'll give them to you.
'Cause it has to be vanilla.
Yeah.
(audience laughter)
- I think we should just
have a conference with him.
Look at the questions
we have left on there.
- Are you hiring?
Absolutely.
(audience laughter)
Because that's the other
thing on the flip side it's been
interesting getting to a place
with the agency where we're
hiring hefty salary,
experienced people.
The experience is so valuable.
The creativity is the variable.
The strategic
thinking is the variable.
It's can that person take away
the old habits and go more of a
bottom up than
top down mentality?
Right, it's tough for a creative
senior creative to not jump in
the room at the last minute
and change something to justify
their means when
speed does matter.
There's just a lot of things
going on but I think but I will
say this, I think we have to
change is the way we're scoring.
- Okay.
- You know.
Too many things look good and
then aren't and we're not giving
it the rigor because MMM and
creative and the brand people
they're all siloed.
We have to come together and
just own it together and force
creative to prove it's actual
ROI because so many,
I was looking at business early
on that was heralding television
but they didn't mention that
they made an enormous investment
in trade to bump up sales.
It's like for some reason we
have this emotional attachment
to the medium.
If I started VaynerMedia
today we would be an Alexa,
message bot,
top level domain strategy,
vertical video shop.
That's what we'd be.
Because I always want to be
12 to 18 months ahead of the
market, stay alive through my
salesmanship so that when the
market's there you grow.
- So I have a distinct
challenge for you.
- Okay.
- Let's see if you can it.
- I can.
- I've got one minute.
(audience laughter)
One minute left, in one minute
can you tell all these people
what's on the one nugget you
want to leave them with that
they should go back
to their offices?
One minute.
- You're gonna die.
(audience laughter)
I don't know if you've heard.
And I'm being dead serious.
There's so much opportunity.
The people in this room can do
so much if they allow themselves
to play a game based on
them being self-aware about
themselves and what they want
their legacy and skill sets to
deploy against.
We are in a rat trap.
We are in a circle.
We're all saying the same thing.
Anytime, I need new business
to grow, I go play your game.
It's that easy.
I reverse engineer
the human being that's
going to make the decision.
I let her or him dictate the
creative and we go on our merry
way and I want to
shoot myself in the face. Right?
And then I start beating them
up and saying I sold you,
now we're doing none of that. Right?
Legacy, opportunity.
Those things.
This is an amazing time to be in
this industry if you're on your
on the offense and it's
the worst time to be in this
industry if you're
on the defense and
95% of you are on the defense.
And if I've got one of you to
switch from that shit side to
offense today then I feel
really good about myself.
Thank you.
- What a great presentation.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- Thank you, that was fabulous.